[Music]
dude we're just talking about that uh
like outdoor comedy yeah performing
outdoors and we uh I did the uh Great
Outdoors Fest in Calgary it's supposed
to be a one night gig
I but then you're like no direct flights
to Calgary and you're like all right no
direct flights I'm getting in the night
early so I'm [__] I'm hurting I land
at like 2 A.M I get the nice driver but
you ever get the driver who picks you up
and he's like forcing conversations yes
but he's got nothing to say right so
he's like Shaggy the musical artist is
here tonight I'm like oh cool you like
Shaggy he's like I have no opinion on
him
why are you bringing them up
I'm like I'm so tired I'm like okay cool
I'm like I'm trying to like just like
carry the conversation at 2AM I pass out
I uh I had a brutal flight by the way I
literally uh the flight there I thought
I was gonna miss my connection I had to
do the connection through Canada so you
have to go through customs uh on the
connection yeah the woman sitting behind
me screaming like she's drunk she's
screaming she's a stage Mom apparently I
find out later because I turned around I
go you gotta quiet down and the guy some
guy tweets Sam Morel just cursed me out
and tagged me I was like I cursed out
the lady next to you yeah
[Music]
tweeting how much I hated her yeah and
then we get I barely make the connect
flight I'm hurting so I'm there that day
outdoor Fest
I'm like [__] I'm like I'm like all
right the air quality here is bad I'm
opening the show to theovan's closing it
and uh it's not like is it a Comedy
Festival or it's a festival Outdoors
Festival no it's comedy it's like it's a
pure Comedy Festival it's a really cool
that they it's run really well but it's
outdoors and it's like 7 500 people you
know mostly there to see Theo I had some
of my people there but uh we get there
I'm like dude the air quality sucks and
Theo is like nah man it's cool literally
30 minutes later our agent calls us it's
like this the province has shut down
everything oh this was semi recently
yeah oh yeah it was like two weeks ago
three weeks ago so I'm like what do you
mean like no show tonight the air
quality is at threat level eight so I
was like oh my God all right you know so
they call us and they say look uh oh God
they want to know if you'll stay another
day because they think the air quality
will get better and I was like yeah I'll
stay and Theo's like yeah man we'll stay
so now it's day we're three days in now
okay right so day three it's still at
air quality eight
and I'm like oh my god dude like this is
worse than it was yesterday I'm like
choking on the air we do the show goes
great you know we're hurting whatever
but uh
the next day we fly back my agent's
flight gets canceled my connect flight
gets canceled so now I'm stuck in
Montreal for the night turns into four
nights wow I get shit-faced in Montreal
I'm pounding booze and our agents who's
a who's a shark yeah sure if you want to
do a pop-up show in Montreal turned into
a great great night
it would turn into a great night but
yeah oh my God these uh the thing about
the outdoor shows now getting canceled
it's like we couldn't perform indoors
for two years
I feel like I feel like I might my
agent's gonna call me like I got you a
submarine gig yeah
what is Montreal like without the
festival because we always usually only
go up there for a Comedy Festival really
what's Time Square like during covid
right phenomenal right exactly people
have got no the festival's too much I
love it but it's too much it's too much
Montreal without it awesome yeah yeah I
would I went I've been just for gfl but
outside of JFL went for a bachelor party
once and I was walking the street I saw
a group of like really tough looking
guys like walking that street and I was
walking down like all right let's see it
was I was like the weekend it was night
everyone was drinking so it was like
yeah you know it was like oh people
drunk walking the streets I'm like all
right here comes like a group of street
street Tufts you know like maybe like
five or five guys and they were big and
then when they walked past they were
like speaking French and it was so
disarming I was like oh I could beat all
them up at once yeah yeah they would
just like I don't know French but you
know like polyro whatever but it's weird
to see a guy that you think like could
probably rip your head off and then he's
like some of those French Dudes know
Krav Maga like some of them
scarves and the cigarettes that's like
British record but you know like if you
ever go like you've ever been like to
like like some of like the bad
neighborhoods in like London it's very
similar to the bad neighborhoods in New
York it looks the same it's the same
type of setup but everybody has these
British accents so you're like these
people are very smart they're very
intelligent they're not gonna hurt me
but because it's just their accent but
that it's a wild thing um to think when
every time I've been in a bad part of
London I'm like I'm fully safe but
you'll get and the thing in London you
won't get shot you'll get stabbed I'd
rather be shot I think I would rather be
shot to death than stamped to death
personally oh if you're talking to death
to death if you're gonna I'm yeah one or
the other though a shot and I don't mean
through the heart I don't mean it's
gonna kill you let's say a shot through
the shoulder okay in the movies like you
know or once one full stab somewhere I'd
rather I'd rather be it's gonna have you
die neither definitely a shot I'd rather
shot just so much quicker the whole idea
in its cooler story I got that could
mean I've been pricked people it doesn't
mean anything I stab like this is shot
sounds cool how do people like 50 Cent
get shot nine times in one shot and and
they don't I mean is that like it's just
literally is that luck like nine bullets
missed every important part of him
Vitamin Water yep that's the way to do
it
you're so right about the accent though
because I was watching that Netflix show
uh down for love have you seen this show
it's it's people with Down Syndrome
right for love but they're in New
Zealand and holy [__] is being a Downs
in New Zealand a better look than in
America they sound it just sounds better
right oh because of the accent the
accent they sound less douncy seriously
let's let's play some New Zealand Down
syndrome
no I was watching I was like oh they're
like barely dead there it is it's great
it's really important to find yourself
because that's what makes you right I'm
looking for love of a girl who is
brilliant oh he's Spanish
Beauty both inside in our site
man could be funny
companionship
house
it's fine it was look it wasn't my
choice to watch I'm in a relationship
all right oh yeah she was like we need
to watch yeah that's one of those as
soon as you said that I was like Sam
wants to go public that he has a
girlfriend oh no no no no no
women in this show actually and then we
uh it was a woman yelling behind you on
the flight well one of the women in the
movie in this show is uh she's like a
movie star in New Zealand with down to
join movie stars yeah so she's in a
movie but she's in a relationship with a
guy who's not who's not down syndrome
right right so I was like that's and is
that okay I don't know oh like
oh I don't know the rules am I
alienating all your listeners with this
topic right now
I'm terrible no you just mean that
someone with that could be susceptible
to someone preying on them maybe I don't
know yeah but then you're like are they
weaker I don't that's not fair I don't
know because then that becomes a problem
let's say this New Zealand actress gets
really really famous like huge blows up
and they want to make a movie about her
life does that actress then have to have
Down syndrome player or do you have
someone make play Down syndrome that's
the thing well I think remember that
Giovanni rabisi movie where he played
yeah and it just like that's a big swing
dude yeah I mean it's like the Robert
Downey Jr thing in Tropic Thunder You
Gotta Go full you gotta just go for it
because nobody talks about Robert Downey
Jr in blackface says there's no issues
with that people complain about it yeah
but they're annoying people put some
Robert Downey Jr's fault right
like I don't know like sometimes even
with comedy when I'm like if I make a
joke if I write a joke that has like a
topic where I say something crazy and
then you attack me for that joke I don't
understand what the difference is
between that and then if I just wrote it
and put it in a movie or a sitcom and I
had an actor said or I was the actor
that said it nobody attacks that it's
weird because it's all the same thing
it's just doing comedy it's an art form
there's no difference it's just the
medium what you're consuming is
different but it fully affects the way
human beings react to it there's no way
for there's no one for them to attack
you know who did the writer the director
the actor why did you reach them you're
standing on stage with the mic it's you
right but also when Ted Danson did that
he got a lot of [__] remember
did he do it with Whoopi Goldberg yeah
but still if you do that next to a black
she co-signed it
but I think like I don't with comedy
it's like you go up to the line
sometimes you hit sometimes you miss I
found that movie hilarious I thought
Tropic Thunder was a great yeah I've
still never seen it you've never seen it
I've never seen there's a lot of big
movies I've never seen I've never seen
Godfather I've told you this you've
never seen Godfather oh no I don't you
don't need to watch one and two just
watch it just watch just watch three all
right this one is really good three is
good that's where it takes off
Andy Garcia forget Pacino dude speaking
of you gotta watch Godfather so my boys
group chat like my group chat from my
friends from home yeah it is anything
um some of my group chats are named Oh
Oh you mean name them oh uh that one no
that one is not one of the group shots
I'm in with them is called the scum
Bunch
they used to call the Mets the scum
Bunch that one's not named but they they
started sending me as soon as the
wildfire fires in Maui happened this is
how you know like what kind of friends
you have I have conspiracy theorist
friends like heart like they are all in
like with everything as a conspiracy as
soon as they the Maui Wildfire is
happening right away one of my boys like
don't believe this do not believe that
this could just happen like that this is
direct energy weapons I'm sure of it
within like 20 minutes of this breaking
news and I I jumped in I was like this
one I'm gonna have to say you're an
[__] for there's no way like it's it
and now all the testing energy weapons
in Maui well now they're saying that now
the direct energy weapon a laser a laser
But as time goes on there's a lot of
people that are saying now like they're
trying to disprove that it's not direct
energy weapons but the internet now is
showing like what they think happened
and how and firefighters are coming on
saying there's no way the wildfires
could have went the way that they said
it and blah blah blah so I just don't
know what's going on anymore and let me
tell you something as it we control a
lot of space lasers this one was not us
yeah
well the big part of it is that Oprah's
house was miraculously saved and spared
from the fire somehow right that's like
the conspiracy part of it right did you
see the thing where uh all the articles
that said Mark Zuckerberg and Lauren
Sanchez donate a hundred million dollars
to the Maui relief and I'm like oh not
Mark Zuckerberg Jeff Bezos and right it
was Bezos yeah
we don't need a not talk about adding
your name to the card that's a little
yeah it's a little aggressive that's why
I say Zuckerberg
it's the biggest natural travesty ever
right yeah this could be the biggest
wildfire in world history with the most
deeper than 100 million his yacht's 500.
yeah he gave them 20 of his job but what
is he worth he's worth pimpy what is
what is Bezos worth is it 50 is it 55
billion 250 billion so 100 million of
250 billion I 100 he's worth 110 so 160.
that's like so what percentage of his
income what would it be we tried to
figure this out yeah yeah what what
would what would it be so 100 is one
tenth of a billion okay so then there's
660 billion so it's
six 18 100 so what am I doing this right
I don't know it would be like if you or
I gave like a 50 gift card to Outback
yeah right well you know when we
calculated the last time yeah we did
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
there's gonna be a lot of tragedies you
don't I mean he's gonna have plenty of
upcoming you know weather related
tragedies here's the other big one this
is the other big one did you see this
Malaysian flight thing yeah have you
seen this one this conspiracy everyone's
slaves that one huh the guy with a guy
stood up and said you're all slaves to
Allah
um no that wasn't an air flight yeah a
guy they had to reroute to Sydney
because this guy stood up and was like
you're all slaves you were on the flight
no no I was like holy [__] no it was a
news story though a guy stood up and was
yelling your slaves and then he opens a
backpack and takes a Quran out which
like I would never have been so happy to
see a crayon in my life like oh my God
yeah thank God for a Quran I thought
that would be something else after all
this outlaw talk that word should not be
allowed on flights I'm sorry let's let's
start an atheist air yeah let's keep the
religion out of the sky yeah none of us
uh none of us can play unless turbulence
and you can pray but that's the only
time only time yeah no this one is
saying that Malaysian flight uh 370
which like just disappeared like they
could never find it in the ocean it
happened in 2014. I watched it I watched
the uh the documentary
very sad but they're saying like you
know because people are kept getting
calls like from Lev from people on the
plane the days later and it was like
this phenomenon but there's video that
the government just released now from
2014 showing the flight going and it's
got thermal radar and then three orbs
going around it and then it looks like
it goes into like another dimension and
of course your first instinct is like
this is [__] this is [__] but
then when you go on the Reddit and look
it all up it's all this government
people is this footage ten years ago
that they the government kept it under
wraps but with this whole alien Congress
thing over the last couple weeks they've
been releasing footage they've been
released government approved so that's
real those orbit this is all real yeah
and they didn't have they didn't have
they had this the whole time yes and
they weren't giving answers to no no
look you'll watch it shows that towards
the end it'll show it that that is
that's all been you know supposedly
confirmed
um this it's all that's like a green
cartoon plane no but it's like it's in
the middle of the night so it's like
yeah you see somebody's watching it just
come on that's real that's what they say
they say that it's it's real and what
about did you watch the documentary
there was like 20 theories because of
all the other weird stuff that happened
before that well they said that they and
now the if you go deeper into this
Reddit they say that they they eat the
little pieces of wreckage that they
found are either government planted that
or there was some debris from this type
of they think it was either a portal or
they they have no idea oh guys all I
know is I haven't seen a pilot disappear
like that since the writers strike am I
right
think I was a to double back on the uh
uh [__] uh accents yeah right you
have a watch in porn yeah and it's good
and you're into it and stuff but then
after like a minute they speak and it's
another language yeah I'm like I feel
duped and then like I got to change this
I can't I'm not into it I can't do it if
it's another language I can't do it at
all and even the only way that it works
for me is if they speak like they have
to speak English but like broken English
if they're in their language it just
takes me too unrealistic like what is
this I don't know what they're saying
because you're trying to put yourself in
the main character's shoes and you would
never sleep with someone like you can't
picture getting her in the bed if she
doesn't know the language yeah
the the speaking part of it yeah I can't
just I don't know what's going on here I
feel out of sorts I and I also you find
that like a little late and then you're
like you're like this is I feel like I
feel confused I feel duped yes yeah
I don't want to jerk off with also
looking at Babel
you really agree like could you do that
it's another language I can't I never I
have to for the two main reasons why I
just say I can't watch this video is
language barrier and if the man has a
small penis those two things I can't I
can't really why are you here yeah well
because again when you want to Envision
yourself doing it this guy's small penis
takes me out of it I don't want to think
I have a penis as small as him it's like
if Woody Allen was in an action movie
I don't want to see this [__] right put
the Rock in there yeah
no it's true what is this Italians
aliens Who attack Peruvian tribe on Tick
Tock all this stuff went viral because
um Peruvian people in the jungle were
being attacked with machetes by aliens
right but it was actually illegal miners
dressed as astronauts with jet packs
what I don't know something's going on
in Peru Jerusalem Post got the hot step
on this one
you guys catch that story on the online
Jerusalem Post about the Peruvian tribe
with jetpacks it posed as mine
I can't I can't anymore yeah I think
anymore I think that may be a bit though
what you just said yeah yeah maybe it's
maybe maybe that's like porn Rose that's
how we like combine porn with like
Rosetta Stone or something right right
think about how smart we would be if we
were jerking off while learning friends
that's probably seriously yeah because
we're sponges
well you're never more attentive that's
when you listen right yeah yeah look at
this I think this is fake do you guys
think this is fake this woman is
creating a new gender and she identifies
as Trans financial for me it's clearly
fake and just doing a bit but people are
getting actually mad at her in the
comments here she goes
so I identify
which means that I am a rich girl
stuck in a broken body and that is one
of the hottest things that I have to
deal with in life
get out of here it's a bit but I but
come on but the thing is but the thing
is with this is people now like on the
comments like they really are taking
this seriously and they're like is this
just another kind of thing now we have
to you know not disrespect oh I get it
because I'm transatlantic yeah I feel
like I have to fly to Europe but I don't
want to I don't want to right yeah right
yeah his financial sounds like a really
exclusive Bank exactly it does it sounds
like except uh Caitlyn Jenner it sounds
like like like like a stadium tour on
Bert's fully loaded tours he's doing
Trans Financial Field
um yeah I think that it's it's I mean
this is what happens though is like you
have a movement you have something
that's like doing a good thing that's
actually helping people but then so many
other people co-opt it and do what they
want to do with it that now you can just
say anything and you've like thrown the
baby out with the bathwater yeah oh yeah
yeah baby out with the path water when
was the last time
you out with the bath border I've said I
actually said it yesterday because the
people I'm sorry I said it this morning
because the people were selling our
house and the people who said that they
wanted it came for an inspection
yesterday and then it turns out they
didn't want it because they said that
there was some structural beam issue
which is probably BS and then I said I
said I think that they're you know
basically having one minor issue that we
would gladly pay for wasn't that much
money to pay for it we would gladly pay
for it but instead they've decided to
throw the baby out with the bath water
and just walk away from the house okay
that's yeah I like some of you these uh
yeah like like freezing like that yeah
it's fun yeah I I I I've been as I've
been getting older I've been talking to
my mom more and my mom she go I used to
I talked to my dad a lot so but I've
been talking to my mom more and my mom
is big into phrases like that baby out
with the bath water
um she'll say what's cooking good
looking a lot um she'll say uh what's
other ones she used oh she calls a
hallway of vestibule that's old school
she calls a fire hydrant a Johnny pump
there's something rotten in Denmark what
is it you ever hear that one yeah I just
watched True Romance the other day and
they say that more than once what's it
called rotten in Denmark isn't that yeah
I don't know where I don't know what
that means but it's kind of fun yeah
yeah yeah it's like this doesn't add up
this is [__] and it's called rotten
in Denmark yeah yeah I know that one I
never heard yeah something's rotten in
Denmark I've also never been to Denmark
but I'd like to go you ever go Denmark
Copenhagen I don't believe so I would
love to go there no you have the comedy
or anything no festivals and [__] there
you ready for this plan though what do
you guys think of this plan and it's
already been it's already been confirmed
by my family that they're in next June
next year the Mets are playing the
Philadelphia Phillies in London so I was
going to go there to do a couple of
shows in London before the Mets Phillies
game you know I would go you know have
fun my friends from home will go but
then I was thinking what if I just got
an Airbnb in London and I just stayed in
the UK for the entire summer brought my
family and just used London as like a
home base like I'm living in New York
and then on the week weekends go do
shows in different parts of the UK and
just like spend my entire summer in the
UK and I brought it up to my family and
they were like we'd love to do that and
we just get one Airbnb home base and
then during the week travel see
different places and then go on the
weekend go do shows and that's how it
kind of you pay for the trip
is that a stupid idea you sound like a
transatlantic that right you have to
bank a lot of these though you have to
that's the thing a summer so we're
talking about 12 to at least 12 apps
right but I have to bank that or you
could take it some or you could just
take a summer off of pause your fans
ain't liking this all right
let me let me tell you something oh yes
that was overworked
but you know uh London's great I love I
I just did gigs in London it was fun as
hell yeah a little trip to Greece
London is amazing but you lose you know
what's funny when you travel you lose
all your status so I was like going
through security there I I have Global
Entry but I forgot to get in the line
I'm doing all I had to take all the [__]
out They confiscated my [__] Lube
when I went through wow which uh that
hurt yeah what do you have lube for why
not
really you think a guy we need Loop what
about a little spit in the hand I I find
that I I I'm you're not a spitter I'm a
giver I I like it to be uh natural
sensitive Lube I I think about the other
person to begin with not if you need it
no I mean why not if you moved to
masturbate no it's for sex the other
person okay no because I wasn't no
because I don't know because I oh that's
right you were with her I thought you
were just with Gary veteran you're like
well Peter now for him too he rubs it on
us when he said
it's so nice to have your friends on the
road with you it's the best yeah beat us
with me next week oh did you bring veter
with you to the UK I didn't I didn't I
no it's uh I I bring him domestically I
bring them everywhere everywhere yeah I
brought James yeah
you don't get to see the bright lights
of London yeah I only did a couple gigs
there I feel like in London too every
time I'm there it feels like you know
like like they've almost they're such an
older country than us because there is
something to like they're like us as
people as American citizens we have like
a way of thinking when we're here and
like you know we get influenced by like
the politics of the day whatever but
London is Dave the UK has been through
all this stuff already they're so old so
I feel like they're a lot less stressed
out over there like every time I'm in
London it's like very calming yeah and
relaxing because I just feel like they
don't they're not all about like every
dollar make it not everything's about
money with them which is it's about like
having more balance that's what I think
I don't know though I could be wrong I
could I'm also there for like a week at
a time on vacation drinking pints every
day that's what it is I think everywhere
you go I'm stressing about money but I
think you know yeah depends on your
mentality when you're yeah your
mentality yeah I agree I I feel good
when I'm out of the country because I'm
never out of the country did you fly you
fly what is the flight to Greece from
London like an hour two hours it was
short that's what's amazing to me is
like you can be in a city like that and
then you can just fly for a weekend and
be in a completely different culture
where here it's like you have to that
you it's going to take six hours for you
to get right to anywhere from there yeah
interesting
Santorini Athens oh my God I missed the
wildfires by like uh like about like two
weeks they were like I wouldn't go to
the Parthenon today I was like please
it's not I mean this is like the most
American thing to say I'm like I've been
to Phoenix you know
I mean it was
it was Bill in the park over there they
have a replica
I'm good oh God greases that's why they
live so long that food is so healthy man
healthy and yeah and then and they're
balancing out with the cigarette smoke
yes but but speaking of that yes they do
live so long and because we have you
know uh Venetia venetia's Greek here off
camera she's but here's the here's the
thing now what's happening now
to pimpy I sent this into your text I
found an article that said women are
starting to die now because of over
alcohol use because of the boozy
brunches and because of the you know
what fine wine night so women are
starting to die now in way higher
numbers than alcohol deaths increased by
14.7 percent for women everywhere
everywhere what how many brunches you
think that is women are really starting
to I mean women are starting to get
smacked It's the funniest way to die
though it's the business the doctor just
comes in like did you go to brunch on
Sunday
how many mimosas did you need no what an
embarrassing death sentence because it
said like women they you know there was
like this common misconception like
women can't get cirrhosis of the liver
women but it's it's it's not true so
watch out ladies watch out you're all I
mean we were drinking last night we us
and our ladies were we were we got we
got drunken Sal came over yesterday and
we got hammered in my house we finally
did a non-work social yes
we had to like let's do this right yeah
it was in Montreal and we were still
kind of working but we were like able to
get drunk yeah yeah we were drinking
smoking vape pens we had a good time the
kids were sleeping upstairs I did
yesterday it was good we were very adult
we weren't like sitting in like a around
like we were in a conversation room not
TV or nothing yeah by like the fireplace
and we were sitting in chairs like
facing each other like talking and
drinking wine dude
tiramisu yeah the kid wine and vaping is
the funniest combo
doing shits on The Vape person but when
you're hammered and someone hands you a
kiwi mango
what
it was good man and I got to tell you
from The Vaping and smoking weed
yesterday which I don't I've been doing
it more now but not I don't do it that
much I had a bit of a hangover today but
I felt so much happier like waking up
and like coming driving into the city I
felt like like it definitely did
something to my mood like it stabilized
my mood where I was just happy and even
The Hangover I was like just deal with
this if I didn't have the weed I think
it would just be the depressed presence
of the alcohol lingering and I'd be like
so down on everything but I wasn't that
way at all I think it's because of the
weed and I've been micro dosing
mushrooms I have that again yes that's
psilocybin yeah I'm telling you dude it
does something I don't mind I love by
the way you're talking about like women
dying from brunch and you're like I
drank I smoked weed I shroomed
it wasn't much needed I can't do
psychedelics I don't like drugs that
hide in my awareness I like to I I'm in
my head too much so I like to uh I like
to push everything down when I when I I
don't know how drunk is that alcohol oh
I feel like you just kind of silenced
the well I I I weed I used to do a bit
about this helico I smoke weed it's like
I had a party in my head and only the
worst people showed up that's how I feel
but alcohol I just feel good it's just
like a positive voice you know how many
nights in a row what do you think your
record is in your life for nights in a
row you've gotten drunk nights are like
you've been drunk what is the record for
you
unfortunately like probably pretty high
but what is it what do you think the
number is I don't know maybe like I
don't know not that and lately I'm I'm
so much better because I was like sick
the last week so I kind of you know I
don't drink when I'm sick because I
don't want it to keep going but uh I
thought things were looking like lately
I'm better last week I was sick so I
couldn't drink
oh it sounds like you're getting better
well the problem is we have a Mark and I
have a drinking podcast which you guys
have both been on I love that you're
drunk yeah and we you know we get day
drunk and I tell people like they
cheered we did a thing in Montreal and I
was like I hope you're [__] happy
because it's killing us it is like
taking a toll on our health well also
you have you guys have your own whiskey
we have a whiskey Bodega cat uh which is
available Bodega catwhiskey.com thank
you I have a home and I I drink I love
potato dude it's good whiskey you know
it's uh it's toughness problem with a
podcast where you drink is like it's
it's required drinking I like when I'm
like I choose to drink right now it's
like tough when you show up at 2 p.m on
a Tuesday and like we got a drink again
dude so we we're taking it a little
easier lately but uh so you can't drink
every podcast well you have to have a
drink every podcast yeah but somebody
every once in a while my sober guest and
we have a sober guest we'll be like we
have Joe list on him he doesn't drink
we're like I love coffee that we could
do coffee yeah you could change it too
yeah but it's hard I mean the friends is
so fun because I'm always like I
shouldn't drink and then you're like one
and a half two in and you're like I feel
amazing yeah she was right that's it I
mean you're at two and you're like all
right but see I like what we did last
night I had one or two Tequilas a little
bit of red wine so not too much alcohol
that's just a little bit but then the
weed and I felt like I was like I'd
rather have less alcohol now I'd rather
have like one drink yeah and some wheat
some edibles or something like that and
then just close but I can't control the
eating yesterday after you left I ate
two uh tiramisu cops and another three
slices of pizza at midnight and you
already broke your faster I threw the
fasting up out the window last night
yeah but you're looking rib man you're
looking like but it's not you have
yesterday I was I I woke up today with
puffy nipples I was a puffy boy this
morning yeah you got it you got to
release it though that's the thing I
feel like what's been happening alcohol
comes out in the morning through both
nipples through both yeah yeah I milked
it yeah I I you gotta have balance
though you can't always for so many
months for almost a year now every day
I've been like not deviating from
fasting only once a week but I'm like
you can't [__] live like that I mean
but you do you look like a young
Charlton Heston right now thank you you
do yeah I I uh I don't I I well I I feel
I walked here I've tried to you know
vanity and I were doing uh Christmas at
my podcast studio and she you know was
like are you gonna give me a ride to hey
I said absolutely not I need to walk off
my alcohol I'm walking it off and then
you walked here from there today I did
but but I was it uh what is it a mile
about a block yep two blocks but then I
stopped but then I stopped at this
Market Roger Hill Market something
market and I said I'm just gonna get
myself an iced coffee and then what I
wound up doing is I sat down and had the
iced coffee I was like just let this
iced coffee here you got a couple more
blocks you're going to feel good get
balanced before you know before I left I
had eaten a pepper cheese croissant a
bacon egg and cheese on sourdough and a
blueberry muffin no you
yeah
the food is like it's like a binge it's
like a famine no no seriously the people
on my patreon were like dude like not
even they're not even like you have an
eating disorder you have the definition
of an eating disorder you cannot you you
so so the fasting helps me with like not
get out of control fast sometimes you
just have to go but then it's like it's
either full of eating disorder how did I
do like I don't even know why I did that
I wasn't conscious at all you probably
have anxiety so you have probably yeah
from all the weed I'm smoking I get
enough for both of us but you know but I
think it's got to be related to food you
must have some like it's must be some
coping thing
back your relationship with
you know what I'm saying well let me ask
you a question though when you're so
into a your body is diligent because of
the way that you've set it up because
you're fasting and you do that and you
dump all that in you do you not like
feel like you want to do does your body
not shut down from all that like it's
like a 4 000 calories at once when
you're not even used to eating that kind
of stuff yeah I I I don't look fine I
don't know yeah actually it makes me
feel like happy and like I am who I'm
supposed to be when I do things like
that like I know who you're supposed to
be is Brendan Fraser and the whale yes
that movie looks like an exercise in
misery which by the way is the only time
they say exercise in that movie
no just like movies were it's just like
he's a 600 pounds like I don't want to
watch this [__] and actually I wound up
I was watching on a flight and I've
watched like the first 30 minutes and
then I just kept fast forwarding and
it's the same scene over it's just him
fat you know with his trying to rekindle
with his daughter but the whole movie is
just set up in his basement because he
can't move so I'm like this movie's
stupid and then at the end he like
floats away into outer space I'm like
what a dumb way to find the Malaysian
plane yeah that's why I did it yeah you
were joking at the end did you just give
a complete spoiler about the ending what
do you mean he floats away you gotta see
his eyes right I'm guessing he floats
away they they float they you don't the
ending is up for interpretation you get
it's like I can't tell if you're
breaking my shoes no I swear yeah there
you go breaking my shoes is is pre-dates
breaking my chops yeah yeah I um no he I
don't know yeah he just floats away it's
like a big beam of light and I know I'm
like did this guy get abducted by aliens
or is he dead I don't know
I have no idea at the end of the whale
yep he floats away into space in a beam
of light not space but he yeah he's like
he floats up yeah Google the ending of
the whale an image is stupid the whale
floats away yes it's very dark
regardless you do have food related
anxiety it's something you should talk
to with that you talk to your therapist
about no but I want to download that app
Noom because they say Noom is a good app
that helps you changes the psychology of
how you approach food it's not a diet
it's a way of life so you don't you
don't feel bad after you eat all that I
do I do I feel horrific but I think it's
the same way maybe how somebody would
like binge drink yeah I just do it with
eating and you deal with the hangover I
guess right and I just deal with so for
me I'm like well I'll go work out today
I'll try to have a salad I'll try to
balance it out but I probably won't do
those things huh it'll probably get
worse but how often does that occur
don't beat yourself up over that
especially when you know well now way
less that's what I'm saying it happens
way I think this used to be the way I
lived like this used to be just the way
I ate live my life always I was doing
this every day yeah you've been smelting
how do you stay spelled
a lot of basketball like in the Park
yeah uh uh I do not overeat ever I I eat
but I eat pretty healthy I'm a pretty
healthy eater like oh really I eat a lot
of if I'm at the cellars and I eat like
fish or like kebabs you know right I
want to yeah I don't eat you know I look
I'm in New York Jew I definitely eat
bagels and I like my you know carbs I'm
gonna do I can't cut out carbs it was
people who are like cut it no I [__]
love I do not eating desserts and pizzas
and cheeseburgers that much I usually
yeah I usually instead of dessert I I
don't have the biggest sweet tooth so I
usually crave like like a Negroni or
like uh right or like a old-fashioned or
something I like I like alcohol so uh
but I've never seen I've never seen you
uh all years I don't even like oh you
look like you put on a little bit of
weight never that's hard to do I'm sure
some of it's metabolism like you know
but uh
I just uh
you and Mark are the most ripped podcast
Mark is ripped I'm not Mark is like Mark
looks great shirtless I look like
[__] I look like Marcus Marcus going
to the gym and then all of a sudden he
would sure he has like a six-pack a mark
is completely Rich shredded yeah yeah
Mark doesn't eat bread he like doesn't
like bread
the way you feel bad he feels bad after
he eats bread really so he just eats
he's keto all the time he like wraps and
stuff but he doesn't like like big he
doesn't do I don't think he does bagels
or pizza or anything which I can't Pizza
is a thing like especially in the winter
like you smell Pizza late at night
coming you know I'm like dude I need
pizza yeah yeah it's like the most I eat
New York food I love New York food yeah
yeah I can't live without Pizza I can't
live I can't live without pizza and I
really can't live without chocolate
though I I just need those things Pizza
chocolate was the best we had last night
what about when you go to the clubs and
this the menu is God awful well I'm with
Gary veter on the road usually who's the
biggest food yeah I'll eat him he
probably doesn't do this you as much as
he does to me but he always is like he's
like he's like [__] you better pay five
stars he's like my girlfriend
essentially we'll go and he'll be like
this is this food's not good enough like
he'll get angry yeah
Gary doesn't care about my health either
like we were in Phoenix one weekend at
stand up live and I was like I should
have canceled the shows but I just never
cancel if I can move and uh I'm on the
couch like passed out ill luckily I'm
not a high energy comic so I just go up
and talk like this but it's not a great
sales pitch for my shows
[Music]
and it's you know boiling hot and I and
I pick it up and I'm like oh [__] and
I'm just burning myself and he's
pointing and laughing at me
learning myself I pass out all he can
talk about is you were supposed to take
me to Pizzeria Bianco this weekend
[Laughter]
Bianco he sounds like my eight-year-old
yeah he said he every time every time we
hit the road he goes I found a
restaurant it's gonna cost you big time
buddy
and I can't resist making him happy so I
always do it it's so funny man yeah I
mean man Gary doesn't carry one of the
the anything he literally pitched a show
to me called Gary doesn't miss he's like
the show is I picked the restaurant you
pay for it and you pay for all the
production costs I'm like you know
there's people who do shows like this
with like culinary backgrounds yeah you
you're just an [__] you're not
he has a web series Gary doesn't miss
you pay you have to be dead honest and
he can go as long as till he misses but
then when he misses something's gonna
happen to him see that's the show see
how cause he never misses because it
doesn't miss and he doesn't miss because
he just picks the highest rated
restaurants I mean it's easy to not miss
right
80 entree or whatever yeah it should be
a good piece of fish or steak Yeah
uh yeah this guy said he lives on a
cruise ship for 300 days a year because
his bills are cheaper than renting could
you imagine living on a cruise ship for
300 days a year what bills do you have I
don't know all right game time yes game
time app I love it game time lets you
buy tickets to major events sporting
concerts Broadway at the last minute for
the best price they guarantee their
price you can check out where your seat
is online so you can see the view you're
gonna have they have Flash Deals yeah I
mean we love game time forget planning
months in advance game time has deals on
tickets right up to the day of the event
the game time guarantee let me tell you
about the game time guarantee this is
awesome you will always get the best
price if you find tickets in the same
section and roll four less game time
will credit you 110 of the difference
just slap Sal just slap me right across
my face that's what it is and that's it
so stop uh wait until uh planning months
in advance you don't have to do that
anymore and I actually grabbed a Lionel
Richie at Madison Square Garden seats
game time boom yeah Davis he canceled
yeah yeah you've been having a lot of
fun lately without me I just want to
we'll talk out we should we should join
forces snag the tickets without the
stress with Game Time download the game
time app create an account and use code
hey babe for 20 off your first purchase
term Supply again create an account and
redeem code hey babe for 20 off download
game time today last minute tickets
lowest price guaranteed all right this
Show sponsored by betterhelp if you've
benefited from therapy better help is
right for you whether you're dealing
with decisions around career
relationships or anything else therapy
helps you stay connected to what you
really want while you navigate live so
you can move forward with confidence and
excitement that's right babe entrusting
yourself to make decisions that align
with your values is like anything the
more you practice it the easier it gets
yes if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
entirely done online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule all you got to do fill out a
brief questionnaire get match with the
licensed therapist switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge so let
therapy be your map with better help
visit betterhelp.com hey babe today to
get 10 off your first month that's
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash hey babe trusting it's
eight my alarm just went off and what is
it saying have a better help appointment
in just about 10 minutes here
better help what you what I love about
it is when you trust yourself to make
decisions that align with your values
it's like anything the more you practice
the easier it gets that's why I use
better help and like Sal said go to
betterhelp.com hey babe Gonna Get You 10
off your first month go do it I love it
and I love when you repeat things I said
for emphasis
what's up everybody I am on the road
right now just announced a lot of dates
for my tour they're on sale right now
you can get tickets at salvolcano
comedy.com I'm coming to Bowling Green
Cincinnati Toledo Wilkes-Barre
Wilmington making Savannah and Athens
Georgia I'm coming to Peoria Rockford
and Springfield Illinois Cedar Rapids
Duluth Appleton Rochester Davenport and
Elkhart Indiana gearing up to film my
special in Chicago uh in December tune
in next week I will give all the
information about the special taping but
until then Savile County comedy.com and
I'll see you guys on the road what's up
everybody I'm so excited I'm back on the
road after three months off now's your
time to come see my new hour that I'm
doing I'm proud of it we're gonna film
it as a special this year this weekend I
am in Atlantic City New Jersey
and then in September I am in Los
Angeles Portland Seattle
Las Vegas New York City we got some
tickets left for the theater at Madison
Square Garden September 23rd and then in
October we're in Nebraska we're in uh uh
uh um what's the other state Missouri
Kansas City St Louis Hammond Indiana
we're coming all over and then we got
November December January February dates
christycomedy.com really proud of this
new hour now's your time to come see it
go buy the tiki wikis baby yes
and let's talk to them about merch real
quick real quick ready let's talk about
merch baby let's talk about you and me
let's talk about all the hey babe merch
you could have on your body let's talk
about merch wow wow oh my God blacked
out yeah
we just re-upped on some March this
isn't it but yeah that's it but that is
shout out Prince Paul is wearing
blackface
but yeah guys check out how do we where
do they get merch I don't know
nope no pressure Z kid doesn't get
easier than that no press.com go get
them I don't know pimp oh that that
I don't know he lives on a cruise ship
22nd to the 26th 2024 co-hosting with
Eric Andre going to the Bahamas for
Miami we're booking it up again now the
hangover's starting to hit damn that's
gonna be trying to get here you've been
on the cruise dude I remember doing the
cruise the shows were actually pretty
good for a cruise show like the your
crowd is cool so I remember we did one
show and my favorite memory was getting
off stage I did a show with Richard Voss
and who I love and uh someone walks up
towards and points to me and she goes
you were my favorite and boss turned so
he goes oh yeah well your other friends
are prettier than you
a lot of other people it was so fun no
if you want to go on again let me know I
don't I can't do that I can't do both
it's not personal I love you Bert wanted
me on his two and I was like I can't I
will die if I go like the way you're
worried about food if I go on a cruise
with Bert Kreischer I will not survive
right that is bird is built different
yeah I tour with him for an extended
weekend it was me him Nate and Kyle
Kinane oh my God and that's [__]
crazy yeah and we would wake up every
day and get to the airport like at the
crow and he he would sit at the bar and
drink at the at the airport I mean I'm
not I'm not outing him he just took a
pint of beer down another pint before he
got on the flight he had three or four
beers it was unbelievable but then he
would get on the flight and be the party
of the flight he gave him a fight on his
own pick up the phone and just start
talking to the whole the whole plane
like he didn't even get he wasn't even
allowed I was like he didn't get
arrested and we just left yeah yeah
he's a shirtless in first class
I just picked up the phone no he's the
most fun yeah I mean he's he's insanely
fun to be around that was that was it I
would tell you the time we went to
Chicago theater on that trip and we get
into the week we all arrive we get up to
the Green Room we sit down this guy and
it was guy in this sitting already I
figured it was he was one of them or I
figured he was with the venue or
whatever so we get in there someone's
aren't in a shirt we're talking
someone's making a drink wasn't it 20
minutes talking to each other just the
four of us in this guy
real personal stuff and then like 20
minutes in the kid goes I go how are you
uh who do you who hi who how do you know
what do you know who do you know and he
goes I got to be honest man I'm just a
fan
and we said why because I'm just a fan
ago
you don't know any of us he goes no he
goes I just snuck up here I just want to
hang with you guys wow and we all
thought he was with the other person he
stayed with us for like a half hour
that's what happens when you hang with
like a party animal those dudes find the
way I remember uh years ago I did the
Borgata with Dave Attell and Jeff for
Austin when they were like you know
doing their co-headlining thing when
they were kind of like just starting it
and I go to Jeff Ross just anyone he
would meet he would be like uh you know
oh just come to the show come to the
show any literally anyone would be like
he's he just walks around in a social
and you know a tell is kind of just like
hiding from everybody so I go to Jeff
Ross's room I assure you not there's
like 60 people in there I'm like how do
you know him and like oh we're
accountants we met him at a sandwich
shop in Philly and I'm like what yeah
and then I go to David tells room it's
just him alone with a cigarette and he's
like he's like oh God and he doesn't
want to deal with any of it like you
know Jeff's family would come in to say
hi and he'd be like this is my aunt and
Dave would be like oh great another aunt
everyone's got their pre-show ritual
like Jeff wants to be schmoozing to tell
wants to be writing you know it's like I
think I'm in somewhere in between I know
I can meet a couple of people but I
can't I I I I I you gotta like have five
minutes of just like I gotta center
myself you know this shows are maddening
when you do local to like when your
friends and family and they all come and
it's like tons of guests that's insane
when you're trying to like focus and
it's just like all your friends all your
family are there it's just like well I
got I'm doing Atlantic City this weekend
Friday and Saturday this week yeah this
show this episode comes out tomorrow
right pimpy yeah so yeah I think there's
only there's a couple of tickets left
for the Friday show Saturday's gone but
awesome it's fun it is a fun room it's
fun and um and the room is actually kind
of good yeah as far as casinos go yeah
it's it's not bad but that one is it's
like a close it's like a home gig but
everybody's going to AC to party it's
like Vegas you know close to New York so
that one's tough to deal with because
not only will I have to deal with my
friends and family coming but they're
all going to be coming in drunk and
wanting to do things and wanting me to
get them into things and and so like
that is like a big I get always get over
anxious when I'm doing shows in AC
because everybody especially means
Staten Island it's like yeah everybody
goes to AC yeah so it's like I've
already like I woke up this morning I
had six texts from six different people
asking if there were any how do I it's
the same how do I get tickets to your AC
show this weekend how do I do it I'm
like just will you shut up you just shut
up you've never used the internet before
yeah anytime just know if you're
listening at home and if you have a
friend who's a comic or you get into how
do I get tickets we know exactly what
you're doing just I'd rather I'd rather
you honestly just say listen I know we
barely talk but I want to use you to get
tickets into a show that I don't want to
pay for so if you could do that just
email it to me you piece of [__] and you
would get the tickets quicker from me
saying that then me you trying to beat
around the bush of what you really want
what about this one what about hey I
went to get tickets but it's sold out
when it's not
and
[Music]
what do you think is an appropriate
number to ask for comps okay honestly
though you're saying is this a family
member not a family member
not a person I don't know well but he
does he he's not our money guy he's a
separate guy I have another guy who
handles like stocks and stuff two I
would say two four is really pushing it
six call the police yeah he has trade
wow yeah no that that's a federal
it gets better I tell my mom because I'm
like I don't know what is this like ins
and my mom that's funny bro my mom goes
give it to him it's what she says really
and my poor manager goes he's a dick so
I'm like the twin manager deals with
tickets more my mom is like he handles
you money you gotta always appease
people like that okay speaking like a
Jewish stereotype and uh just whatever
he wants don't they feel like like they
can like why not support you why not
support you well that's whatever I'm
fine giving tickets but once he had
eight and here's where it gets better he
goes I can't make it but my eight
friends
and I'm such a piece of [__] I gave it
to him
now listen but at least he told you to
happen where they and then they just
show up and they're not there and they
go oh where's Sonic and John and like he
couldn't make it when he don't even tell
you they're not coming that's happened
to me too it's brutal yeah yeah it's but
also like I think like four is is like
the big number I think that's like the
four you know yeah anything for for
listen unless you own the stadium then
it's like that's I guess there's
somewhat of a difference there but like
actual like the actual artist comic
musician if you ask them specifically
for the tickets that's a lot but I guess
if you're like you know I guess even if
you ask an owner of a stadium or owner
of a team that's too many tickets too
I'm sorry to the Cohen family for always
asking for men's tickets
you know what you're going to be dealing
with tooth day of even the people who
gave tickets today well I know it's an
Atlantic City sometimes they're like
where's it where is it again what's the
address or even better like it's like
five o'clock like hey what time is it
yeah I'm just just look at it I was
doing the beacon I was doing The Beacon
Theater last year you know big biggest
show I ever did in New York
my mom my mom like the show's at seven
at like 5 30. she was like leaving she
goes hey honey have a great show she
goes do you want me to bring your mail I
have some mail at the house do you want
me to bring it I'm like yeah that's what
I want give me my mail from a car loan
from eight years ago that still has your
address
in the middle says she hands you a Mount
Sinai bill yeah thanks thank you for
that yeah what are all these antibiotics
you have to take honey dude I it's
insane well my mom what you do us too
now because a lot of the mail still goes
I'm 38 years old a lot of the male still
goes to her house you know because it's
like her address is still on my license
whatever so there's times where hospital
bills will go to her house and she'll
bring them to me but she opened them and
she retapes them I'm like this lady's
looking and I'm like Mom I know you're
taping she's like well you're my son I
have to make sure your health isn't
checked I said that's what I said I said
I can arrest you for that she's like
who's gonna watch your kids I was like
you're right
I was just in St Louis right and I was
like I passed a weed store I'm like oh
let me get some weed you know and I went
in I bought the max allowance whatever
right I don't want to go back it saves
me trips so I was gonna take it on the
plane but like 25 of them are pre-rolls
and I didn't want to go through a thing
and they see 25 joints then it might be
a red flag usually I I go with flat like
edible or whatever so like let me mail
it all right I'll just mail it so I went
to is that okay to do I don't think so
so I I don't know I don't think so but I
how is it not I'm not
listen if the post office can steal
ballots and lose balance they can listen
but I'll say so I put it in a box
I wrap it all up I go to fedexa I ship
it I spend money to get it overnight it
doesn't come four days later it finally
gets out to call complain get a refund
gets to my house I take it I open it
half of the weed was gone what and the
box was re-taped back up so it smelled
like it smelled like weed and what what
this person at FedEx did was probably
like there's weed in there I didn't know
what else they knew there was weeding
there he can't report that because he's
not allowed to do it I'm gonna open it
and take it when he opened it it was all
weed and he had to leave something in
there and he took they took they took
350 worth of weed that is insane I taped
it back up and I was like I'm gonna call
FedEx and I'm like I can't I'm like I
don't care I'm still gonna call him I'm
gonna say what I did I don't care we're
both going down seriously remember the
old uh Hedberg joke I like the UPS guy
because he's a drug dealer and he don't
even know it yeah That's crazy dude yeah
yeah man how much are we the amount of
money of the win today 350. yeah dude I
feel like that I wonder if that's you
can federally charge someone I'm joking
true well dude how about here's the
thing here's the thing with you know we
trust you know people who are working in
FedEx or you know when you go to like an
office or something like that like they
so many people have full access to your
address your way everything it's just
you have to trust that they're not going
to do anything somebody I went to a
doctor for nothing like a [__] just
like blood pressure I'm on blood
pressure medicine you just gotta check
your blood pressure every few months to
like still see if you need the
medication I still do and and and uh I
walked in it was like a you know regular
doctor's office and uh one of the guys
behind the counter recognized me he was
like oh Christy I was like hey what's up
bro and then I go in whatever nothing he
says buy nothing you know whatever like
three days later I get a screenshot DM
to me no from this guy he's like open
about it he's like dude you don't have
bad cholesterol your numbers are fine
and then and I was like you're not the
dude what that's again so I would think
no I was like that you lit I mean I'm
not the kind of guy that's like you're
done you're fired but like I told my
social media guy was like respond to him
and just say dude that's not cool you
did that don't do that again to anyone
that you recognize I'm shocked after you
telling us your diet that you don't have
bad cholesterol that is insane I know
to the doctor I'm like I'm intermittent
fasting I lost all this weight the
doctor like hey you look good and then
cholesterol is still 390 and I'm like
yeah well because in that six hour
fasting window I just eat cake with my
hands
cholesterol
boundaryless I know my doctor's approach
to me is like let's with you let's just
tackle one thing at a time we got the
number down you got back in the gym so
now the fasting is good you got that
locked in your mind now in that window
let's try to get more vegetables less
cheese and then so it's like little by
little he's like this is We Got A
Five-Year Plan you're in good shape him
you're in Grace you're good about the my
blood my blood pressure is actually much
better shout out losartan uh my blood
pressure is good I took it 127 over 70.
127 over 70 first shot not bad I take
mine cholesterol is going to be a
nightmare but I'm on like eight
medications I can't but I'm not guy what
medication you're a very neurotic
Italian yeah
it's not even Italian I I I I swear to
God the people that I I literally relate
to the most I think are like older black
women and older Jewish men yeah anyway
uh yeah
antidepressants and I'm three different
blood pressure medications and now I'm
doing starting from my ADHD as well but
I also take a lot of vitamins you know
yeah but I take vitamins I take I take
athletic greens that's not even a plug
is vitamins though that's good that's
why I take I just want it done to me I
hate the taste but also that's a good
thing about I come to like the taste it
doesn't break a fast either athletic
greens it does not break the thing about
uh I started drinking so young that I
think I just like I like the kind of
nasty taste like you know I like the
liquid NyQuil I like the liquid the
liquid uh yeah
I like it my daughter my little one she
we gave her Motrin once like it's like
bubble gum flavor motion she cries like
almost every day and she's like oh
Motrin she wants Motrin like that's like
chocolate milk like you can't just have
medicine every day but that's how Motrin
gets the children seriously yeah we tell
but now if she's even like slightly got
a temperature we just give her the
moment wait till they come up with
bubble gum uh fentanyl oh yeah that's
the good stuff you thought it was good
before guys yeah baby this is [__]
this is how we get the kid the kids home
now you're positive we talked about this
last night but you're positive that the
weed that we buy in these weed shops
which are technically legal in New York
cannot have fentanyl in them because
they are packaged by a company there's
no way fentanyl could slip in yeah yeah
no one opens packages at the post office
yeah I mean look you got to go to a
reputable place to make sure you buy a
reputable brand and all the information
is on a sticker on the box it's sealed
and it should have a barcode and should
have a manufactured day to strain and
and a serial number and all that stuff
does that help do you guys both smoke
you said do you does it help your
anxiety or does it make it worse uh I
felt better about it my anxiety for the
most part it lets me turn off my brain
at night and and go to sleep and relax
but there are times I smoke and I get
neurotic and paranoid and I have to pull
myself back but I'd say you know most of
the time it's it helps you're by far of
the Joker's the most neurotic when I
watch the show
no it's not even it's not even you're
the actual emotional but Murr just as a
physical being looks the most like you
would be yeah I'm normal jacked up man I
was talking to Jessica Carson once we
were talking about like oh how Comics
are all usually are all messed up and I
was like I was like no but not me you
know I just feel like I don't I don't
think I had any issues I feel like my
childhood was good I don't feel like she
said that no no me Jessica no she's no
she she was like and I was like I just
feel like I'd like to make people laugh
but I've come to realize I am I am
really really really really messed up
I started comedy taking her comedy class
she used to teach a comedy class then
she took me on the road with her she
might be the only really great comment
she's awesome Jessica she's awesome and
that's why I don't know I mean because
she's so [__] funny we went on the
road and she you know we had a great
time and then you know at the end she
made me eat her banana out of her but
that was it but did you cramp up on
stage I did it well there you go maybe
Lego was on oh yeah yeah oh yeah beep
that curse oh yeah yeah please yeah this
is a clean hey babe it's a clean podcast
a family-friendly podcast
um yeah anytime you hear us curse it put
that hey babe over it so we want we want
your money back rocket money hey baby we
need your money we just re-upped on
these shirts it's sold out yes we did so
if you want to get this hey babe merch
we just got a few more in grab that out
that's on our website and then where can
they find you and what do you want to
plug some guys I'm all over the road MSG
theater November fourth uh can't wait
Chicago Theater September 30th Toronto
uh September 21st I'm going backwards
for some reason Phoenix coming up well
the Jews they read the opposite way
I got York uh Bethlehem Pennsylvania uh
when did this come out tomorrow tomorrow
oh yeah freaking help Providence
Burlington Albany this weekend and uh
Northampton Mass which could use a few
more times oh yeah dude you're on on the
founding fathers Tour all the worst
places in the summer they're like all
college towns I'm like I work year round
and then uh
anything oh la coming up and something
else uh I'm forgetting oh Ohio I'm all
over Ohio Cincinnati Columbus
uh Cleveland Indianapolis I'm all over
the world in Australia baby in November
I'm doing all over Australia that's
gonna be fine I know you gotta watch you
have Netflix specials YouTube specials
yeah and you have that we might be drunk
and then any other podcast was just the
we want no right now it's just we might
be drunk uh with Norman and uh yeah all
over the road Netflix special I got this
uh up on the roof of positive influence
on YouTube and uh yeah there you go love
you guys thank you Sammy one of the best
there's been hey babe
thanks
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away feelings babe don't be afraid
don't be ashamed don't hesitate to say
hey babe hey babe hey babe hey babe hey
babe